here's a question have you ever been
given a second chance yep and if so what
did you do with it this morning our lead
national correspondent that would be
david begneau introduces us to gabrielle
perry she's a louisiana woman who was
given a very unique opportunity david
we've been waiting all morning for this
story good morning to you here we go
good morning my friend look we all make
mistakes but not everyone gets someone
who believes in them enough
to take a risk and give them a second
chance that's what this story is about
so buckle up for a valuable life lesson
and a surprise
the life of gabrielle perry has
benefited from second chances that all
began when she was born and given up for
adoption i am
the birth child of a woman who was
incarcerated
and that was the story of how i came to
be into this world the woman with that
bright smile learned firsthand about
second chances by watching her adoptive
father thurman perry run his louisiana
lawn care business
they don't make men like my daddy no
more the only people that he hired were
the men from the local jail they were
from the prison work release program
he never treated them any differently
did he do that because he wanted to give
them a second chance i believe so in my
heart i really do mr perry died before
he could see his daughter go to lsu
but in your personal life back home
they were foreclosing on your family
home
your mom was sick i mean it was just
everything was falling apart and
desperation led to a lot of poor choices
while in college she got arrested i
had
taken money
that i did not earn from my work-study
job
i got caught of course and immediately
confessed to it
she was charged with 27 felonies and
even though she paid the money back she
had to face judge beau higginbotham
he just
was so kind to me and
he asked me
if i was ready to go back to school it
was almost like it was a collaboration
like we were just having a meeting about
my future i feel like i was meeting with
an advisor and this was the judge on my
criminal case and
there was just so much humanity in that
moment and it really changed the
trajectory of my entire life wow
wow
the judge decided not to give her jail
time
and that was another second chance dear
judge higginbotham it meant so much to
her that she wrote him a letter i stood
before you just about seven years ago as
a first-time non-violent offender
when you called my case you were
incredibly kind to me
your decision to not punish me saved my
life and because of that i get to go
save other people's lives now too in
deep sincerity gabrielle angelique perry
[Laughter]
oh my god hi miss barry how are you it's
nice to see you again sir i didn't think
they would bother you with this no
they're not bothering me at all i keep
your letter on my desk every single day
it gives me inspiration to do what i do
every single day he took her to his
chambers to show her he wasn't kidding i
took a lot of care in making that letter
i really just never thought that it even
got to you i
i just sent it because i felt like been
sitting right here
even after the judge showed mercy to her
she struggled we are in the place that i
was homeless the longest
bathing in a bucket walking three miles
a day to work that was her life she says
for nearly three months after her arrest
my peers my sorority sisters everyone
kind of just led the charge in just
isolating me
and that experience gave definition to
what has become her passion project the
thurman perry foundation
named for her daddy
the foundation gives financial
assistance and essential public health
resources to women and girls impacted by
incarceration my education saved my life
being able to educate women and girls is
not just a nicety it's a public health
measure it's a public safety measure and
that leads us to tamika starks the first
of more than a dozen incarcerated women
to get a 1 000 scholarship from the
perry foundation
[Music]
they had never met until this moment
inside the louisiana women's prison it's
okay we're here together it's a moment
you just look exactly like all your
pictures and i keep all your letters and
that's just yeah and i'm just so happy
yeah i'm happy to see you
and i'm grateful for the work that you
do
you are giving us ladies a voice
so there's purpose in the pain there's
purpose in the opposition
that's purposing your tears
we are very very grateful
starks is serving a 20-year sentence for
manslaughter what is your story about
how you came to be here well i came to
be here through domestic violence i
remember calling the police multiple
times and i also called the domestic
violence hotline a couple times and i
was told to get a dog
to get him talk
so in the moment
instead of running away
i ran towards him
and i shot my husband
and he died so in awarding a scholarship
to her what is your hope essentially
women who are incarcerated
they're erased i want to be able to give
them a sense of dignity and to be able
to give them a sense of purpose just as
judge higginbotham gave to her your
decision not to punish me is definitely
reverberated we have a scholarship
program especially which is honestly a
direct result of you letting me go back
to school i got to pull myself and my
mom out of poverty i got to
i got to be somebody well i played a
very minor role in this you are the
person that played did everything
but in fact he empowered her to go on to
get three degrees including a masters of
public health in epidemiology she is now
a 29 year old epidemiologist studying
infectious diseases
a lot of us move through life and
people are nice to us but it doesn't
stop us and give us pause
what is it about kindness that gives you
such pause
there's been such a lack of it there's
such a lack of it in the world in
general it's like you forfeit that by
having crossed through
a jail cell
it's like you are no longer worthy of
that
and i don't believe that and so when
someone is kind to you
it has the ability to literally change
the trajectory of your life
i'm living proof of that
oh wow there are so many layers to that
story david begna i don't even know
where to begin
the judge higginbotham wow wasn't it
cool bringing the two of them yes by the
way the judge didn't remember the moment
seven years ago but when we called and
said hey listen would you we're bringing
her could she read the letter in your
courtroom he said i gotta meet her it's
been on my desk and sure enough for two
years it has sat in the corner that says
something about him though i love when
she said it was like talking to a
counselor as opposed to the judge who
was supposed to sentence her in the case
yeah and you know when we talk about the
public health resources she provides
feminine products to the women's prison
in louisiana and it was really the
orleans parish sheriff who first took a
chance on her because she said listen
women need organic feminine products not
this stuff out of the machine that have
you know strips in it that aren't
particularly safe right and so they
believed in her they bet on her and now
every quarter she delivers these to
women in the prison system and so
it really just shows that you know
people who have a record who committed a
crime they are not what they did on
their worst day yeah with their worst
decision they're so much more yeah and
on top of that individuals that have an
opportunity
have influence on somebody's life and
can change that yeah send them in the
wrong direction saying no you are your
mistakes or just like judge he saw
something naked you know what you are
not your mistake yes i'm not only going
to get out your way and let you go
forward i'm going to lend you a helping
hand and encourage you to speak that
into your heart that is incredible can i
just say something about gabrielle's
hair i love her hair pretty fabulous
when i was a little kid if i wore it
like that my grandmother would say girl
go comb your hair now that's an actual
hairdo my daughter wears her hair like
that a lot of people do and it's just
really striking out and proud i love it
yes me too i am so fascinated by a
single moment of kindness and what it
has the potential to do
change this woman's life thank you so
much